HERE WITH US TONIGHT.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THIS.
IT'S FASCINATING WHAT SHE'S
DOING AND SOME OF THE ARGUMENTS
ARE THAT THERE IS CHAOS, I DON'T
THINK THERE IS, I THINK IN FACT
IT'S POSSIBLE IT WAS A POINT A
LOT OF LONG THAT THEY KNEW WHAT
THEY LOSE CONTROL.
THEY HAD NO INTENTION OF CARING
ABOUT THE NATURE OF WHAT THE
CONSTITUTION REQUIRED OTHERWISE
IT WOULDN'T HAPPEN THE FIRST
PLACE.
>> TO CLAIM WE HAVE TO RUSH
THROUGH THIS WITH ALMOST NO
EVIDENCE AND WITNESSES OR
ANYTHING, BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
A RACE TO NATIONAL SECURITY AND
A THREAT TO THE REPUBLICANS,
NOBLE LIED ABOUT HER STOPPING
THE PROCESS AND HANGING ONTO THE
ARTICLES.
I THINK SHE HAD A COUPLE THINGS
IN MIND, FIRST OF ALL SHE WANTED
THE ARTICLES BEFORE THE FIRST OF
THE YEAR TO DAMAGE THE PRESIDENT
IN ELECTION YEAR AND I THINK
THAT BACKFIRED.
SECOND OF ALL, I THINK SHE WANTS
THE INFLUENCE OF THE SENATE
TRIAL EVEN UNDER ARTICLE ONE
SECTION THREE OF THE
CONSTITUTION, SHE HAS NO POWER
OF AUTHORITY WHATSOEVER.
IF SHE'S ACTUALLY TRYING TO
ENGAGE IN A QUID PRO QUO, AND AL
OF A
OF I'LL
SEND THE ARTICLES OVER TO YOU IF
SEND THE ARTICLES OVER TO YOU II
APPROVE OF THE PROCESS THAT YOU
DESIGNED AND SHE'S DOING EXACTLY
WHAT SHE IS FALSELY ACCUSING THE
PRESIDENT OF IN THE QUID PRO
QUO.
OF >> Tammy: OBVIOUSLY,
CONGRESSMAN, NO SHAME.
I THINK WHAT THEY'VE
UNDERESTIMATED HERE IS THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE'S REACTION TO
THIS.
IT'S A SHAM, BUT IT'S MORE THAN
A FRAUD.
THEY ARE DOING THINGS THAT
DELIBERATELY DAMAGE THE REPUBLI
REPUBLIC.
TO SAY THIS ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES WHEN
MONUMENTAL THINGS ARE HAPPENING,
AROUND THE WORLD, FOREIGN
POLICIES AFFECTED BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THAT HE MIGHT BE VIEWED.
YET, YOU'RE IN THE POSITION
WHERE YOU NEED TO RUSH BECAUSE
IT AFFECTS WHAT YOU'RE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH.
>> YOU HAVE REAL FACT WITNESSES
AND I MADE A REQUEST AND
DOUG COLLINS SAID A LONG LIST
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT ABOUT
WITNESSES AND WE DON'T HAVE TIME
FOR THAT.
THEY'RE IN THE MAJORITY, THEY
CAN CHANGE THE RULES, AND IT
ALLOWS FOR A MINORITY WITNESS WE
DID NOT HAVE THEM MARTY
WITNESSED A BECAUSE TIME WAS OF
THE ESSENCE.
IF WE HAD TO MOVE ON AND GET
THIS TO THE SENATE.
IF I DON'T THINK SHE THOUGHT
THIS THROUGH AS WELL AS SOME
PEOPLE THINK.
SHE DID NOT WANT TO GET TO THIS
.9 MONTHS AGO AND THEN SHE
PUSHED INTO IT.
>> Tammy: OF COURSE, SHE WOULD
HAVE TO BECAUSE IT EFFECTIVELY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
PERHAPS, ALSO, THEY'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THE FOCUS GROUPS ON
THE POLLING THROUGH THIS LIKE
WHICH WERE TO USED TO ACCUSE
HIM.
PERHAPS A WAY TO SEE TO IT
PERHAPS A WAY TO SEE TO IF ANY
OF THIS IS AFFECTING, AND THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE OPPOSING
IMPEACHMENT ARE GOING UP.
>> I THINK SHE'S HOPING THAT IT
WILL AFFECT PEOPLE EVEN THE
LONGER THAT SHE HOLDS ONTO THE
ARTICLES THE LESS LIKELY THAT IT
IS AND WILL BE A BIGGER
BOOMERANG EFFECT.
THE OTHER THING IS, FRANKLY, I
JUST THINK SHE KIND OF HOPES
THAT SOME MAGICAL EVIDENCE WILL
DROP OUT OF THE SKY.
LIKE WHICH IS AN WITCH HUNT
WHICH REALLY DON'T EXIST.
>> Tammy: OR IN FACT, WHAT
STARTED THIS MAY BE ANOTHER
PHONE CALL FROM ANOTHER
ANONYMOUS WHISTLE-BLOWER WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE MORE INVESTIGATION
AND IT'S A WASTE OF MONEY AND
CERTAINLY.
THE OVERALL DYNAMIC,
CONGRESSMAN, IS ONE THAT TELLS
THE PEOPLE OF THE COUNTRY THAT
WE'VE GOT TO CONGRESS THAT IS
NOT DOING ITS OWN JOB.
IT IS TRYING TO STILL UNDO -- OR
STOP AT A ELECTED PRESIDENT AND
OF COURSE, IRONICALLY,
BECAUSE WE KNEW SOMETHING WAS
WRONG WITH CONGRESS AND SO WE
WERE PUTTING HIM IN THERE TO
CLEAN THIS UP AND AWAY.
IT'S AN BATTLE THAT IS
OCCURRING BECAUSE THESE ARE
INCORRECT IN 2016.
>> IT BECAUSE MANY OF THE
DEEP STATE THAT WE REALLY DIDN'T
HAVE IDENTIFIED A PERIOD OF THEY
POP THEIR HEADS UP.
THERE WE GO.
IN THE DAYS WE WILL BE ABLE TO
ELIMINATE THOSE SO THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL HAVE MORE
COOPERATION WITHIN THEIR OWN AND
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Tammy: PELOSI, GREG, HE'S
ARGUING THAT MITCH McCONNELL
MADE IT CLEAR HE'S NOT GOING TO
BE THERE.
THEY WANT ALL THOSE THINGS --
THEY KNOW, THEY KNOW THEY
WEREN'T BEING FAIR AND NOW
THEY'RE AFRAID LIKE MOST
LEFTISTS AND THOSE WHO PROTECT
THEY WERE OF THE SAME THING
THAT'S HAPPENING.
IF THEY WANT FAIRNESS, THEY WANT
WITNESSES, THEY WANT THE SAME
THINGS.
THIS IS CLEARLY A POLITICAL
ACTION AND THAT'S WHEN
IMPEACHMENT IS.
McCONNELL HAS NO OBLIGATION TO
EVEN LOOK AT THIS SHAM THAT'S
BEEN PROVIDED TO THEM.
THAT'S ONE OF MY CONCERNS, THE
ARGUMENT -- I THINK THEY'RE
RELYING ON THE PROCESS THAT THE
PROCESS WOULD MAKE THEM SEEM
LEGITIMATE WHERE IN FACT,
McCONNELL HAS EVERY RIGHT TO
BE SERIOUS ABOUT HOW HE LOOKS
AT THIS.
FOR CRYING OUT LOUD, A MEMBER OF
THE SAME PARTY.
>> IT'S IRONIC IF NOT
HYPOCRITICAL AS NANCY PELOSI TO
THE DEMAND DUE PROCESS OF THE
SENATES THAT SHE APPROVES WHILE